hello welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly chat show every 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on gamespot.com and
available on demand on the youtubes and
GameSpot
I'm your host Danny no Dwyer do you know
how worried we were about this week's
show there's like nothing happening in
January so it's a good thing the bunch
of people decided to leave their jobs
I'm so happy to say hello to previously
for my G mr. Greg mode hey I find a
funny kind of funny now everybody kind
of support us with Greg's funny and I'm
like not that funny so don't we even it
ok you're kind of kind of fun
calamari are you thank you very much
coming at you we appreciate it and
they're writing at this em man which we
have on the couch this week mr. Chris
waters hey Danny
hey Dino buddy I still have a job as you
say you can have media it's over it's a
dinosaur is dead what will the Phoenix
see how do you think we feel when like
ign's like for did we got the other two
sitting over there just tweeting about
the producer sexy-looking start you know
from Pier 1 Tim Gettys Oh Nick look at
you I buried on awesome my thyroid used
to look young they were present that day
very well that was 2008 Nick 2008 what
does it say if you guys are leaving like
come on what about the enthusiasts
game's pricey what you're trying to say
here it was time for us to go about what
we're trying to say hello you mean no
there's no overarching statement IGN
gave us both eight great years yeah I
mean it we've been there and we had
grown there and you know in measurable
ways yes and you know it was time to try
something different yet exactly we've
got for sure 15 faster life um you know
it was a great run it was a great ride
and just towards the end once we really
got started doing our own YouTube stuff
with kind of funny that started to pull
us in a certain direction and we didn't
want to fight that anymore
yeah so you had game or for Gregor your
YouTube channel right forever you guys
did that sort of rebranding at some
stage so yeah like I said yes September
yeah it's hard to say this weird to say
last year right yeah seems like not long
ago but in September yeah like dialing
back even further yeah like two and a
half years ago two years ago launch game
over dragging my own YouTube channel
where I was reviewing Oreos and talking
to Colin
and it started I came back from this
thing called VidCon which is basically
GDC for youtubers you go there you
learned what YouTube is all about and I
remember I dreamed sending me there
because I was doing up at noon and like
you say you to show you should go and
learn about you too much
I know YouTube and you get to this thing
and you're like I didn't know anything
about YouTube I didn't know anything
about what this thing was and how
popular it is and how it works and how
it's a game in itself that's really what
draws me to it right you put up a video
and it does that number you like well if
I tweak the headliner I did this with
the thumbnail how can I make that better
next time if they're mad flix exactly
mad clicks also you know serve the
audience we were building but at a time
it was more like just to screw around
and do stuff and I came back and I told
Colin let's do a show together he's like
I know he's gonna want to watch me talk
about stuff no Mike no idea what you say
crazy things and then a NIC antenna I
was like Nick come help me film I don't
know how to work camera and he's like
all right and I'm gonna grab him because
he understands YouTube like great and
they want to accept money they accepted
pizza in the beginning but the call and
I were so excited we got the first like
hundred twenty-five dollar check for new
man so the three sorts of exactly a lot
that Google agile ended up yeah and so
yeah we did that for a long time and the
more we did it the more fun it became
the more it was like this outlet both
creativity you know for us to get out
there and do different things and then
for us to connect with this you know
audience that we have through we had
through podcasts beyond up at noon IGN
but bring them into a different
direction do something you know cool
with them and it was a wonderful ride
and we really really got invested and
everybody started taking you seriously
and that's why it's September you know
we decided to rebrand it's kind of funny
because it was weird you know for Nick
to go out at things be like yeah I work
on this YouTube channel and they're like
oh what's a call like game over draggy
and they're like what are you Greg he's
like no you know I mean that was a weird
thing for people to wrap their heads
around so we rebranded to be more
diverse and start building a product
that you know one day knock on wood if
we don't go anywhere we can still let go
like we can step back from one day when
you want to leave you can work they're
kind of funny and then value to green
cars can we get married
yeah actually as soon enough I'm sure
that will happen to by the time we cross
that bridge now I think I'm gonna be
stick around here for no no joke man you
got a great gig get on it uh yeah and so
this chair you wanted this chair was a
young soo films
spare bedroomm you said very nice so
when was it that you guys were like
taking a seriously thinking you know
what all right we're going to be done
with what we're in our current jobs like
was a back in September presumably it
must have been like way further back
than not that least it was an option
yeah I mean we started talking about it
last year and the four of us and we had
a weekly kind of standing lunch where we
would just talk about you know our
business and what we were doing and it
was a side business and we were
exhausted all the time cuz you were
always filming at night and and when we
decided it was at VidCon last year when
in Anaheim where we've kind of decided
like you know what to explore our
various options about how we can fund
something like this and we stumbled upon
patreon which i think is a really
awesome option because I've been very
outspoken against Kickstarter in the
past I had a lot of concerns about us
going to directly to the users be like
you know do you want to fund this thing
and then I realized in talking to the
guys and and researching it and
something like it's just a subscription
model it's yeah instant gratification
it's Netflix its Amazon Prime I'm like
I'm comfortable with that and so let's
move ahead so we actually launched kind
of funnies original patreon in September
when I was at Oak in Tokyo a Tokyo Game
Show and we were we thought we got a few
thousand dollars and would be nice we
maybe buy a new camera in a few months
and and we were a snap we got $10,000 I
think it in one day and um we were
astounded by that and also nervous about
that because it was like one good that
made us make choices start to make a
series of choices that we had that we
inevitably had a man yeah and then come
October I went home to Long Island uh to
see my family I was on the phone with
these guys every day eventually New York
Comic Con around that time we decided we
were going yeah we really and now you
guys are set but between the initial
patreon and this new one for the gaming
aspect of kind of funny you're sitting
at it's about 28,000 like a lot of
people are saying like that's kind a lot
of money like that's insane to be
getting that much but you know Bay Area
rent on its own is sharing saying like
what is the reality of having the four
of you guys existing on a month-by-month
with that type of income what we're
about to find out now I mean we is
definitely pay cuts from what we were
doing at IgA yeah and it's one of those
things we are we talked about for a long
time is that you know it's high risk is
high reward is the fact that we knew
leaving we would take that step back and
we have multiple revenue streams
so it's not just the patreon numbers to
look at we have obviously YouTube
Adsense on top of you know we sell
shirts like this one here district lines
complex kind of funny
um and there's all these different
angles to you know we sell the podcast
early even if you don't want to do it
now we're doing yet which we have that
um it's good it looks like it's good
this is our we're ahead of our
projections right because the biggest
thing for us is for the longest time
before October we would talk about
what's everybody's number to leave
you're not I mean like right we have to
make it when you start talking like that
it's so far-flung on when we'd actually
make enough money to leave and do this
on our own and what was it the changer
for us was patreon not because patreon
gave us enough to live but it started
bringing that number up right like as we
get going and we do gain YouTube
subscribers and we do gain podcast
traction then you can start selling ads
and do this the patreon number can stay
where it is we can make money on the
other side and then get back to where we
need to be where we want to be and so it
quickly came not what's the number we
need to leave but like what could the
number be if we left right right because
what I was talking about is the fact
that you know on you you know up until
you have to do two days ago before we
announced we had 80,000 subscribers on
our YouTube channel every video did
about twenty twenty-five thousand views
and then on patreon we had eighteen
hundred subscribers yeah and so you can
see it real quick start paring down to
like who you're hardcore people are and
if you're looking even at 1800 or you're
looking at that eighty thousand these
are people who are showing up to enjoy
our content totally not getting what
they wanted you know Colin and Greg are
passionate video games that everybody
knows everybody weren't allowed to touch
the stuff when you're working at idea
exactly I mean and I've talked about
this on our show yesterday and a whole
bunch of other ones right like IGN's
been fantastic yeah I mean when I came
to them was like I want to launch a
youtube channel they're like well
technically that's a conflict you know I
mean you're the host and your public
personality for us that but we want to
let you do this we want you to be happy
but you can't talk about games and then
we talk about this gray area of movies
and TV and comics right cuz I didn't
covers all that and so the aunt would
the gray area we seem to be happy with
was like alright we're gonna talk about
movies and comics and stuff but not in a
way I can would want right like we're
you know we'll talk about like what's
the best movie car or whatever something
like that or like you know
Breakfast Club memory something you
wouldn't see on IGN on a daily basis and
that was fine but then we started
butting up against that wall of like
well now we have this audience that
loves us and is rabbin and we want to
serve and that's what this keeps coming
back to you know like on beyond I've
always said if you listen that show you
our best friend but you understand then
I say that on a game of regression I say
that on all of our properties because
it's true by listening to us about
coming in I get the relationship I have
with the viewer with the podcast
listener right because like the whole
point of the show and why it works is
because we're all friends and so your
your v friend you're the fourth friend
of what show you're listening to and so
we want to give them what they want we
want to serve them in the way they wanna
be served
so speaking of podcast beyond presumably
the right level IgM yeah yeah I mean
that's the thing is that you know
podcast beyond is near and dear to us
yeah built it but like you were saying
before like you've been on since episode
one like I'm 78 yeah and we just did
episode 376 and live right now and I
Gina yeah it should be yeah we how does
that work it's so freelance now okay so
now we freelance it I mean the pot gets
beyond of something that's near and dear
us like we we really love that podcast
and we love that brand and we built it
into something what and I think that
it's you know like it's you know up
there in popularity with you know iTunes
all the time with we can confirm then
bomb cast all these great podcast we're
really proud of it is easily the biggest
PlayStation podcast in the world and
it's said that we are eventually have to
say goodbye to it we tried many
different ways to be able to continue to
do the podcast and this was the one way
that we can continue to do it for an
indefinite amount of time yeah but that
podcast much like IGN is very near and
dear to us I mean IGN
you know I'm 30 years old now and I was
18 when you know Beth start college when
they contacted me as a GameFAQs kid they
start writing for that yeah a fax yeah
gamefaqs you and I love game fax I will
great deal to that website and I've been
connected to IGN intimately as a
freelancer and then as an intern and
then I graduated college they offered me
a job and and I owe them everything we
owe them everything they understand that
so there's going to be little things
with pockets and beyond an IGN where
we're always going to be intrinsically
connected to this website we're totally
fine with it endless product the thing
is that IGN will obviously live on
without us and a couple years no one
will care that we're gone if not sue
right now and a nonsense to Mexico go
kids perfect and guys having beyond that
you in the street like five years from
now we're in the street begging for
change this is a huge mistake
that man Papa go back in the day the
enthusiasts priceless I tell you what
they never get playstation allstars no
credit cards yeah they didn't but uh
yeah and we're always gonna be attached
IGN we owed on everything so we want to
be really clear about that too that you
know there's no bad blood practice great
blood like we we we decide we're going
to even told them a long time ago and
and they've been really great to us Fran
and parent al having nothing short of
really awesome to us but we have to say
goodbye to that brand and we have to say
so we have to take about a gene we have
take about a podcast beyond eventually
it'll live on I feel like we will always
be the spirit of that show and I don't
think that that's ever going to change
because I think that we did it for so
long it's like Carson or something like
that not that Greg is Johnny Carson I am
I want to spread that around we can
spread that around we start that I wish
we just did but but it'll it'll live on
and it'll change and evolve we did you
know we did podcast me on live at PS X
and it was huge was awesome at standing
Ramona was great but we had one of the
founders Jeremy Dunham on and it was
funny how we had a segment of the
audience that really knew him and we had
a segment Owens had no idea who he was
you know and I was like well that you
know when they do episode 600 pockets
p.m. we're gonna be there you know so we
can't take ourselves too seriously in
this regard you know I mean the other
thing I just wanted throw in because
Greg was saying talk about the money and
then the financial realities I Jen was
very good to us financially too and it's
this move is not about money because if
it was we would have done yeah so we you
know I you know games journalism and
this this enthusiast press is very
well-known to not you know pay its town
very well um unfortunately were there
long enough and respected enough that
that wasn't a problem for us really you
know and we want to be happier you know
and we want to connect directly to the
audience in a way that we think is best
so it has nothing to do with the
finances there's nothing to do a bad
blood it's really about this jump that
seems illogical yeah so now that you
guys are doing the kind of funny thing
that it's always been a tough question
for you I imagine in your line of work
as has been for me what is your answer
now when you are at a family gathering
and
someone comes to you and says so what do
you do yeah Iida faulted a while back to
saying I'm an Internet personnel area
are you am youtuber now though I think
so or so yeah I mean I guess so that's
what I mean I'm a Twitter I'm a youtuber
on patreon I'm a dot-com owner I'm a CEO
it sure makes it sound like you're like
coming off a mess I am that was another
thing way to kick not enough money to
keep that habit going no yeah internet
personality is what I default to now and
then they stay ask more I say I host
shows on the internet and if they say
what I love the cat buy them did you
expect that this would be something like
you guys been in the industry for a long
long time yeah did you ever think that
this was likely to be something you'd be
doing in your thirties no I mean I wrote
I haven't actually posted yet but I
wrote a really long letter to everyone
that I want to post when our websites
like we're kind of ready to receive it
and uh basically saying that I wrote at
gamefaqs as a teenager for fun like it
wasn't I just like writing you know my I
always say I love video games my biggest
love is history actually and politics
and I always assumed that I was going to
go in that direction and I really I did
I mind my tattoos I went to Northeastern
for American history and I was about to
start you know getting the grad school
and all those kinds of things when they
offered me my job no taxation that yeah
uh very subtle and uh you know so it's
it's one of those things where you look
back and you're like I remember being 18
19 20 getting my little freelance checks
and being so excited you know and I
remember being really comfortable just
being a freelancer when I was 22 when I
got hired where I'm like I didn't expect
you know I still say that as far as I
understand it for editorial I'm the only
person in IGN where it as long as far as
I know that was offered their job that
they didn't like really interviewing or
anything they were like you want to come
it's serendipitous that you graduate
because someone is leaving and I and you
know I'm so thankful for that but I
didn't expect it and I certainly I
didn't even on this is a sad story but I
Greg knows this but like when I moved to
San Francisco from Boston when I went to
school I didn't even unpack my bags for
like a year because I expect like I just
got to lived out of like like I was Anna
dorm room where I was like I eventually
have to move my the other she was going
to drop in the video they're gonna send
me back to Long Island and I'm gonna
upload my dad and go home and disgrace
and it never happened and so eventually
I comfortable and before you know we're
you know kind of old man and so they
know where we are now old yeah we well
we well soon enough
sure we'll watch a new patriotic copy
right right yeah I didn't see it coming
like it was never you know I the story
for me always goes that you know I since
the fourth grade wanted to write about
video games and that's why I went into
journalism that's why they all these
different things and I remember early on
in my IGN career within the first month
one of our satellite udders came to
visit we all went out to dinner with I
mean a couple friends and he sitting
there eating you need you guys so like
what's everybody's playing like where do
you hide jeans not gonna be the end of
the road for you guys and like the other
three guys at the table were like
awkward sounds like well it is for him
and then right and I was like this is
all I've ever wanted to do this is how
it works you know I mean this is what I
wanted to do when I got it at 23 you
know I mean and I was there that entire
time you never walk because a lot of
things either development of community
management or POS but that wasn't exist
yeah you mean I didn't know anything
about the key management as stuff wasn't
even coming my letter so I was I
expected to be there forever and move up
the chain and I moved up the chain and
then you get to that point where it's
like well what's next and the reason I
was able to say it I jammed so long you
see a lot of there's come and go it's
just the fact that I gene let me grow in
so many different directions right like
I was to say to if I it was still a play
station editor which is what I got hired
as I would quit a long time ago right
but I started there and then I was
running the PSP Channel and then I got
to be in charge of the PlayStation team
and then I up at noon came along you
know three years ago changed my life
obviously this is all because of that
opportunity to come out there sorry i GM
turned out to be a bad decision on your
part in the end but I was able to branch
off and do those different things and
it's funny I always trace it back and
talk about when I started at IGN there
is a distinctive video filmed by Ty root
where he walks around and interviews me
about playing a video game and then Dave
Clayman who's playing pacman
Championship Edition and at the end of
it he turns the camera walks away and he
passes pair and pair goes Oh putting
editors on camera what a great idea why
was one of those things I got hired you
know six months after daemon Hatfield
and then six months before turn a few
months before Colin and we were really
the first generation that came in and
like we grew up on this this is all we
want to do and they like all right we
should start putting people on camera
and all the old guys like no way I'm way
to burn down an old for that I like what
I do for like we don't care what I'm
doing like a play off
sure out oh yeah yeah and throughout
right that's just a funny way to play
and I want you to essentially stun the
photograph exactly oh yeah cameras
that's great wait easier than writing
and reviewing well thank you so much for
coming in and talking to us we wish you
all the best
I think it's going to be an interesting
you thank you for you dude